What is up, guys? I'm going be showing
you a super easy money-making method.
All you need is a little bit of GP, and
it'll be super easy. Make loads of money
super quick. Stay
[Music]
tuned. All right, guys. So, what
happened was I decided, you know what?
I've done this before. Let's do it
again. I haven't made a video about it.
I'm going to make one. So, what I'm
doing is I'm buying bird's nests for
super cheap. And then I realized that
crush nests are actually selling for
over 1k more than what you buy them for,
which is insane profits because it takes
literally I think it took me 30 seconds
to do 40 of these. So all you need is a
pestle and mortar, some cash to buy the
nests, and then you just need to use the
pestle mortar on the bird's nest and
it'll turn them into crush nest. And
just continue doing this until you're
done.
and I'm done. So, I did it in about 30
seconds and it took 30 seconds just to
do 41 of them. And so, I instant sold
them for 8K cuz they're selling for
above 8K. And I was like, I looked at
the profits. I'm like, okay, that's
about 70k profit. I'm just going to keep
doing this. So, I'll show you what I did
next. So, I ended up doing about another
41 of them. And it took an additional 30
seconds to do
that. and I put them in the GE and I
decided to sell them and I I assumed
they would sell for 8K again,
but they didn't instant sell. So, I had
to end up selling some of them for a
little bit cheaper, but still made
massive profits. I ended up selling them
for 7,500 each. And now I'm just adding
what I made minus what I paid. So
338496 plus the
656 plus the
0. So
658,152 minus
the 282,000 I
paid
minus minus the
277,240 I
paid equals
98,000k. So the 98k time 60 minutes
because it took me a minute per thing.
Wow, that's almost six mil an hour. That
is insane. All right, guys. Thanks for
watching. Stay tuned for my next video.